[Music]
so hello everybody as the video shows
things get better over time
technology helps things get better it
helps things get smaller faster easier
much much better but how about apps
how will the architecture of apps get
better we're here to tell you more about
our vision for the future of Android app
development discovery and distribution
androids first 10 years have centered
around the app download it works like
this
developers build a large app with all
their features in it people find apps on
Google Play and install the ones they
want and then they wait while play sends
the app to their device and it's been a
great 10 years there are now over 2
billion active Android devices around
the world and play installed close to
100 billion apps and games in the last
year 100 billion but our app model can
get even better so what to improve well
during development building and
publishing for different device types is
still hard in the discovery stage new
users are put off by long wait times for
the download and after distribution
large app sizes these large apps are
much more likely to get uninstalled so
the future of apps will address these
problems development will be more
modular discovery will be more instant
and distribution will be more dynamic
our first step in this direction has
been instant apps and you'll hear more
today about
how its removing install friction and
helping to improve discovery we made
instant apps available to game
developers at GDC this year you can
simply tap the try Now button to jump
into game experiences like this one
King's candy crush saga developers are
seeing that instant apps drives
incremental installs users that would
have otherwise abandoned at this page
are trying the experience they're
clicking try now and then they're
proceeding to install today we're
revealing our related efforts on
development and distribution in the
developer keynote you heard a little bit
about what we're working on in these
areas and we're gonna talk much more
about them now to tell you more about
what we've been working on let me invite
out milena engineering manager for play
app distribution and Kobi product
manager for play app distribution
[Applause]
thanks Matt the Android ecosystem has
evolved since the humble g1 was
introduced ten years ago with over two
billion devices there are new form
factors and thousands of you device
models every year this is great for user
choice there is a device for everyone
but thinking about all these devices as
may development complex some of you use
multi apk to optimize the size of your
app this is costly and complicated
instead of focusing on making your app
unique you end up focusing on trying to
target the right devices with multi apks
the dimensions of device configurations
on Android multiply really quickly so if
you try to optimize by CPU architecture
and screen densities you will end up
with many apks and the number of apks
will grow really really quickly
especially when you start targeting
64-bit in each one of those apks has its
own unique version code although you
release all of them is part of the same
app release this is painful for
developers there must be a better way to
avoid the hassle of multi apk some apps
simply ship everything to everyone all
screen densities all CPU architectures
all languages the results are really
really big apps this is painful for
users there must be a better way
supporting all the different devices
while also adding new features has also
contributed to apps becoming larger over
time since March 2012 the average apk
size has grown by five times this is bad
for users because mobile data and device
storage are both in a premium and users
don't want to have to wait forever to
start using an app or again we can't
reiterate this point enough apk size is
a very real effect
version and successful download of your
app this graph shows you the correlation
between user and user conversion on a
Play Store listing and the size of an
apk clearly the heavier your app the
less likely a user will download it you
may have read about this in one of our
medium posts in this topic for every six
megabyte of an increase in apk size the
conversion rate goes down by one percent
this is a material loss in conversion
rate which can be recovered by focusing
on the apk size but that's not all
bloated apks can also be bad for
innovation some developers are having to
choose between adding new features and
keeping their apps lean for example
Flipkart is a leading e-commerce player
in India where data costs are still high
so it's important for them to keep their
app download size small they're looking
for solutions to keep their initial
install as small as possible while being
able to provide rich experiences for
their users in the long run so we've
been thinking about this how can we
decrease apk size without affecting
development and distribution complexity
well let's look at what's in today's apk
many languages most of which user never
needs duplicative CPU information for
arm and x86 and sometimes even 32-bit
and 64-bit it includes resources in five
or six different screen densities and it
probably includes niche or experimental
features which only a percentage of the
audience will ever be exposed to this
doesn't make much sense a far better
solution would be to only deliver the
code and resources that a particular
device needs and to deliver leaner AB
experience where users could download
additional features on demand so our
vision for solving this pain point in
development is a new app format I'm
happy to announce that today we're
launching the Android app bundle
the Android app bundle is the new
publishing format for Android it is open
source and backward compatible it will
help your users benefit from smaller
apps and you will not need to build
multi apk to optimize the size of your
apps anymore
yes you heard that right multi apk is
finally going away thank you with the
app bundle you only build one thing and
you don't need to refactor your code to
start using it in addition it enables
modular app development which we'll talk
about later in this session so how does
this work on Google Play for end-users
to benefit from the app bundle
we're doing some of the heavy lifting
behind the scene on the distribution
side we call this Google Play innovation
launching today dynamic delivery with
dynamic delivery play will take your app
bundle and generate apks that are
specific to a device with only the code
and resources needed by that device this
means much smaller apps for your users
which is great news for the billions of
new users coming online so let's take a
look at the Android app bundle in a
little bit more detail so here is an
Android app bundle as you can see it is
quite similar to an apk because Dex
files resources assets and native
libraries but one difference you can see
is that it can also include more than
one module in this particular example
base foo and bar this is important for
app modularity which we'll get to talk
about soon another thing you can see is
that the format includes a few metadata
files where you can provide play with
different instructions on how to process
the bundle now how does Google Play use
this format to create a lightweight
binary we use an Android platform
feature launched in lollipop called
split apks if you think about Android a
bundle is a publishing format splits are
the serving format and what eventually
ends up being installed on user devices
when you upload your bundle to play we
will process it to generate splits we do
this with a tool we have very originally
named bundle tool this tool will be open
sourced so you can use it to perform the
same processing that we do for off play
testing and distribution purposes bundle
tool facilitates all the necessary
conversions between a bundle format and
split apk for example generating all the
splits for densities architectures and
even languages selecting specific splits
needed by a particular device installing
splits on a connected device and for
devices on android versions older than
lollipop it facilitates fusing of splits
into monolithic device optimized apks
there are many more options available
with a bundle and the bundle tool in the
next session at stage 2 at 6 p.m. our
engineering team will provide a
technical deep dive about the bundle
format the bundle tool and all the
options it enables ok so you mentioned
size savings tell me a little bit more
about how it happens sure so the big
difference between splits and multi apk
are that splits are additives not
multiplicative for example the app here
has the base apk with Dex files and the
corresponding density ABI and language
splits with dynamic delivery play will
only deliver the density and ABI splits
required by a particular device making
the app smaller for users in addition
play will start handling the new
dimension languages in the Android app
bundle you will be able to supply all
the languages and play will only send to
users the splits for languages they're
typically using in the rare case where
user switches to a new language that we
weren't aware of before play will
dynamically deliver relevant splits to
their device for some apps language
splits alone introduced massive size
savings so we've been testing you with
we've been testing this with few
developers probably some of you are in
the audience right now for example
Twitter is
one of our early access partners by
splitting over languages and screen
densities they are saving 35% of their
app size this is huge and this is not
everything here are a few more examples
text plus with 26% size savings blue
apron with 27% size savings in John Moe
with 50% size savings and that's not all
we have more here are a few more
examples of our early access partners
all these partners have built the bundle
published it to play and were able to
make their apps significantly smaller
look at the results a BA English Airbnb
LinkedIn memorize perigee Pluto TV and
our V app Studios have all saved between
11 and 64 percent of their app size and
that's how Android a bundle and Google
play's dynamic delivery work once you
publish and build your bundle Google
Play will deliver just what specific
device needs now let me invite Karen who
leads Android studio product team to the
stage to tell you a little bit more
about how you build a bundle
[Applause]
thanks milena hi I'm Karen and I work on
the Android team for UB bad guys the Sun
is indeed really bad those are the best
moments when the mic is still on in the
backstage so you've now seen the concept
of an app bundle what I want to do is
pivot directions and show you a bit
about the tools that you're going to use
to build the app bundles in Android
studio 3 - canary that was released less
than four hours ago
so go download it there is full support
inside studio and Gradle to build the
app bundle format the app bundle will
contain everything your app needs all
your languages support for every device
screen every hardware architecture and
will automatically build those into
configurations those configurations into
apk is for you if you're using Android
studio to build a bundle the flow will
feel very similar to an apk working with
an apk today what we've introduced in
the build menu is a new option to build
a bundle if you're using a continuous
integration system all the Gradle build
tasks have also been updated to build a
bundle so replacing a single option
rebuilding your project as a bundle
means that's all you need to do to take
advantage of the apk size savings you'll
also be able to take advantage of Google
play's dynamic delivery so only the bits
that are needed are downloaded to the
device the Android app bundle is your
new publishing format for the store
testing and deploying your bundle will
again feel very similar to it what it
does today in Android studio you're just
working with apk what we've also done is
updated the new run configuration dialog
so you can choose the bundle and select
your deployment target and deploy
directly to a device or to an emulator
Gradle will build the bundle and then
deploy only the ATK's that are needed by
the device this ability to test and
deploy your bundle will simulate exactly
what the Play Store does if you're just
testing your app functionality though
you can go ahead and use an apk like you
did before it'll work the same way and
it's actually going to be faster to
deploy the device
to upload the bundle into the Play Store
you'll need to sign the bundle with a
signing key for all existing apps you
need to provide Google Play with your
signing key so play can process that key
and then re-sign your bundle with the
same key for new apps play will just
generate that apk for you or that's that
key for you if you recall in a multi apk
world you used to have to upload every
apk manually yourself to that store in a
bundle world we do all the heavy lifting
for you you only have to upload one
thing once you build a bundle you can
upload and publish it through the Play
console you will use the same release
flow you're familiar with with an apk in
addition in order to test your app
bundle with your testers you can use our
new internal testing track it allows you
to distribute your app to your testers
within less than a minute when you
publish an a bundle to the Play console
we provide you a new way to look at your
a bundle and understand the size of the
device specific apks that play generates
and delivers to your users we call this
new page the bundle Explorer here you
can see what is the size of all those
device specific apks that plates
generates for every device configuration
for example you can see what is the size
of that apk is it play will deliver to
an arm xhdpi device you can also use
this page to download the device
specific apk is generated by play to any
device model that is listed in our
device catalog we showed you how the
Android app bundle and dynamic delivery
will benefit you in a number of ways for
developers you really no longer have to
manage the multi apk world for your
users we're really hoping that they
won't have to pay the cost of that giant
upfront come install so what does it all
mean in practice we worked with a number
of developers from our early access
program as Kobe mentioned earlier it's
fun twitter has told us what they like
about the new flow with the Android app
bundle they upload one binary with one
version code and dynamic delivery
handles API density and language splits
for Twitter to have done this themselves
it would have required the maintenance
of 500 apks that's not a small feat they
described their build and release
process as more streamlined with the
size of their app has significantly
decreased for their users so you've now
seen how building an app bundle results
in smaller apps and it no edit also
means that you no longer have to manage
multiple apks the second big change of
the app bundle enables is more modular
apps so today we're releasing a preview
of the ability to deliver features on
demand just as building a bundle
automatically builds splits such as
language screen density and hardware you
can create a split for additional
features we call these features dynamic
features and they are installed on
demand each app will then have a base
feature and n number of dynamic features
again with the latest version of Android
studio you can start creating apps today
with dynamic features if you want to
publish that app into the Play Store
however we're still in beta so you'll
need to join the beta program on the
Play Store
although most apps won't need any effort
to create the bundle and support dynamic
delivery creating these modular apps
with on demand features we do expect
will be a longer term progression and it
works fast as you re architect your apps
over time so let me give you an example
of what it means for an app to have
dynamic features in this particular
example we have a camera depot app it's
just a simple ecommerce app there's four
features to pay attention to the first
feature is just to be able to browse
goods the second one to be able to see
what offers you have third being the buy
items and the fourth thing of the cell
you can imagine that from our apps
usage that we see that less than 1% of
people ever use a cell feature and it's
only by people in a particular region or
primarily every person who downloaded
your app has to pay the price of
installing all the features in this case
we should make the cell feature a
dynamic feature so in if a user clicks
on the cell button you'll see a small
user prompt that the feature is
downloading and then it's dynamically
delivered to the device so how do these
dynamic features then relate to a bundle
in the e-commerce app the main browser
application today was what we would call
a base feature you can then extend your
base feature with dynamic features they
deliver to your users on demand in
Android studio we've added a new plugin
called dynamic feature you can extend
your application in Android studio by
adding multiple dynamic features to it
so let's take another example imagine
that you have a video chat app the app
and the main app would be your base
feature you can then carve out a special
feature like augmented reality stickers
and deliver it on demand to users only
with devices with the right camera to
support that feature if you build a new
app you should design your app as
modular from the start thinking
carefully about a lightweight based app
experience and then how you would extend
that out with dynamic features if you
have an existing app we're expecting to
see people take advantage of dynamic
features but carve out specific features
over time so once you've created your
dynamic features you can choose to
deploy only a set of them to the device
as you can see here in Android studio
what we've done is we've also updated
how you deploy the box here shows you
three dynamic features by offers itself
you have full control over which
features you deploy so that you can mix
and match them and the base feature is
always deployed so this framework will
help large apps become smaller and
smaller remain small while adding more
functionality the first step is building
an Android app bundle and the next step
like Karen just described is identifying
features that can be
carved out as dynamic features after you
factoring your code to carve out those
dynamic features you will need to
integrate with the new client library
we're releasing today it's called the
google play core library and it includes
a set of api's allowing you to manage
the delivery of those dynamic features
to your users and in case you want to
deliver a feature as a response to a
user request you probably want to build
a nice user experience around it the
google play core library provides a high
degree of flexibility when you want to
deliver a feature to your users beyond
delivering a feature as a response to a
user request you can also ask to
prefetch a feature when you predict the
user will need it soon or you can ask
clay to deliver the feature as part of
the next update cycle we call this
option deferred installation when
thinking about good use cases for
dynamic features we've identified two
broad categories the first category is
what we call distinct features these
features are logically separate from the
main flow of your app for example in the
e-commerce app Karen mentioned earlier
there is a buyer experience and a seller
experience the seller experience is
logically separate and therefore a great
candidate for a dynamic feature the
second category is what we call
interrupting features those features pop
up during a normal user flow in your app
for example if you have a photography
app you might have an option to add
additional filters during the editing
process this is what we call an
interrupting feature and for those
features it is typically better to use
the deferred installation option I
mentioned earlier to make sure users
have the feature available when they're
ready to use it and of course will be
super curious to see what use cases you
come up with as you start innovating
with dynamic features earlier in this
talk we've mentioned how developers want
to keep their base install as small as
possible
while building rich new user experiences
Flipkart
and Facebook
are two of our early access partners who
are helping us to test dynamic features
for Flipkart as they think about
building for the next 100 million users
dynamic features allow them to ship new
and reach user experiences that are
naturally sized heavy like vernacular
support video and feeds Facebook use
dynamic features to improve the
experience of the app for different
devices while reducing its network and
resource usage they told us that one
thing they really like about the new
framework is how dynamic features are
updated seamlessly as part of any app
update dynamic features enable dynamic
code loading when you deliver a feature
on demand to your user
it can include code resources in assets
as you know apps on Play are scanned by
Google Play protect and delivered
securely to user devices dynamic
features will also be scanned by Google
Play protect which means your users will
benefit from all the same protections
we've been building for years on Google
Play the Android app bundle will make
development easier and dynamic delivery
and is the future of the Android app
model dynamic delivery will improve
distribution but what about the big
thing in the middle we've barely touched
upon discovery I want to invite Jonathan
caramel who leaves the instant apps team
to come join me and to tell us a little
bit more about discovery
[Applause]
thanks Karen
last year on this stage we announced
that all app developers can now develop
an instant app today we're excited to
add games to the mix today all game
developers can now develop an instant
app so let's start with an example of
one of our top game developers that are
live today roll the video please
[Music]
welcome to Google Play instant where you
can get apps and now games instantly and
as you saw in the video when you click
try now you'll launch into a native app
experience that is instant and then
you'll have an option to install and
users are installing more because of
because of this try now button let me
explain how in the old world you'd see a
store listing page like this where the
user has two options install or abandon
and users were abandoning because they
weren't ready to commit to a hundred
Meg's onto their phone without playing
the game or understanding understanding
the game fully but in the new world it
now looks like this so if you are
already coming to the store to install
you're gonna continuing continue to
install at the same rate you have it
before and we're seeing this the CTR
rate for install has not changed but if
you were starting to wander and think
about leaving you now have another
option you have the try Now button and
that will launch you into the instant
experience and allow you to install so
where do you see these instant
experiences well clearly from the Play
Store where you'll see not only try now
but collections and banners that launch
directly into an instant app but the
opportunity that we talked about last
year was nothing to do with the Play
Store it was everything outside the Play
Store because that's often where the
decision is to install or abandon and
that's where the biggest drop-off rates
are let's take ads for example in the
old world I click this ad and I'd land
in the store listing page with an option
to install in the new world I click this
and I land in the instant experience
with an option to install in both worlds
I have to decide if I want to install or
not but now I get to play the game while
I assess if this is worth it to be on my
phone and if I receive a SMS from a
friend that says try out this new TV
show I can start watching that TV show
immediately and then decide if I want to
install the app and if I'm looking for
our new home
Google search I can actually find the
home land in the experience look at the
images assess if I I like the property
and then determine if I want to install
the F the real estate app that got me
all that information now this is great
it's a consumer first experience it's
great for the user but is it good for
developers the answer is yes we're
seeing installs conversions and
engagement go up so let's start with
installs mighty battle saw 19% increase
in installs just from the try Now button
now this is one of the higher data
points that we've seen but we have seen
incremental installs across the board
and as a developer as you expand beyond
the Play Store and start thinking about
all the traffic sources I've showed on
the other slide you'll start noticing
that your new customer acquisition
channel is instant apps take Vimeo for
example which is sitting right over here
they're seeing 15% of their installs
coming from in synapse and nos a news
app is seeing 30% of their installs
coming from instant apps this is their
new customer acquisition channel so our
intern apps just driving users to
install no they're also having great
experiences for the user within the
instant app we go a travel app is seeing
27% increase in conversions within the
travel app where you get new paid leads
from the instant Al and Vicki a tv-show
app is seeing monetizable watch time
increased by 5x so be it if you're
trying to drive installs or you want to
make sure that the user has a great
experience within the instant app
instant apps are doing both now I know
what you're wondering we just talked
about Android app bundle we talked about
in synapse and now you're worried that
you're gonna have double the work you're
gonna go home and have to work on both
things or you're gonna have to choose
one or the other
absolutely not this is part of the same
effort an instant is just a mode of the
Android app bundle so what I'm gonna do
is take you from an Android app bundle
and migrate it to an instant enabled
Android app bundle and then I'm also
going to start with it
and show you how you get to the Android
app bundle all right so Kobe came up
here and said you take your apk and you
get to an Android app bundle and then he
also mentioned that you're gonna start
carving out code and start modularizing
your app so as you go through this
process you might notice that one of
your features makes a great entry point
and you would love that your users
actually instantly jump into your app
that way so if your base module and your
dynamic feature module are small enough
you can just make those instant enabled
and for all that code that is your
installed app that you're not ready to
have part of your instant app you're
gonna wrap that as a dynamic feature
module and you're just gonna make it
available at install time and there you
have it one binary that is both an
instant app and an install valve now
let's see what this looks like if you're
one of the instant app developers then I
see in the audience today so you
probably have something that looks like
this you have a zip file it has both a
base feature module potentially another
feature module and you're going to take
and you did all this hard work to
decrease the binary to modularize
network is not wasted you're just going
to take that same code and you're just
going to make it part of the Android app
bundle and for all that code that's in
your installed app that's not in your
instant app again you're gonna wrap it
as a dynamic feature module and just
make sure it's available and install
time there you are again you have one
binary that's both an instant app and
installed out so now Karen is going to
talk about what this looks like in
Android studio and the tooling that is
coming soon to help you do just that
thanks Jonathan
so let's take the same view of the a
bundle that we saw earlier
you're gonna relate it an instant app
and relate it to an advert Android app
bundle what would that look like
so as Jonathan mentioned at this point
you already have a pretty modular app
built using the existing Android studio
plugins you have a base feature and a
set of feature modules it relates really
nicely to the Android app bundle the
only difference is that your base
feature is now calmed Android
application and that your feature
modules are just using the Gradle plugin
combat Android I'm dynamic feature in
the future will be releasing tooling to
support full unification of these two
formats your Android app bundle will
simply be instant enabled so regardless
of where you start from if it's in
internet moving to an Android app bundle
or an Android app bundle that wants to
be instant enabled you're going to be
covered so as I mentioned earlier
dynamic features you can build them
today in Android studio building apps
with dynamic features but if you do want
to publish them to production they're
still available as preview and you need
to join the beta program on the Play
Store at the same time that we're
releasing dynamic features and making
them fully available we'll also be
working on the tooling to instant enable
your app bundle now let me invite Matt
back up here to talk more about the
feature
[Applause]
Thanks so we've talked about big changes
coming today firstly much leaner apps
are possible and there's no more multi
cap multi apk and secondly dynamic
features are out as a beta now I'd like
to encourage you to imagine how you'll
use these capabilities in the future and
make use of them for your own app so as
you've heard using the Android app
bundle and Google Play dynamic delivery
you'll be able to create highly
configurable modularized apps that can
be adapted to different users and
different use cases so your preliminary
experience can be lean and instant with
additional features provided to users on
the man as they need it which of your
features are only used by a fraction of
your users the capabilities will allow
you to create different versions of your
of the same feature for different device
types such as low memory and high memory
devices it will also enable you to do
live experimentation with different
versions of the same functionality
without making your app bigger and you
can find out which variant works the
best and fuels your success
what sensitive user journeys in your app
like a checkout path could benefit from
that sort of experimentation we're
moving away from a world of giant
installs to a world of modular app
development instant app experiences and
dynamic delivery apps will be richer yet
they'll be smaller and more efficient
both on disk and over the wire we
encourage you to start thinking about
how you use these capabilities to
improve your install conversion start
thinking about how you use these
capabilities to lower your uninstall
rates and start thinking about how you
use them to build richer experiences
that help you to improve engagement with
your app Android apps are evolving and
we're excited to see what you can build
with these capabilities and we start
today all developers can now build
Android app bundles in the latest canary
release of Android studio 3.2 and upload
them to the Play console you don't need
to refactor your app to get started you
can get started on the web at GTO /
Android app bundle and you can get
started with modularization and dynamic
features in the canary - those who are
ready to start publishing apps with
dynamic features can apply to join the
beta on the website to find out more
attend the session right after this one
on stage 2 where our engineering team
are going to share some technical deep
dives about building the bundle and
using the new client library enabling
dynamic delivery thanks and have a great
I own
[Applause]
[Music]